this is the thing the smell hamdulillah
Salam alaykoum peace be with you
hum did Allah all praises to the crater
that heavens and earth it's brought to
you back again you're watching the D
show and I'm Eddy your host and my next
guest will be with us in a second when
we come back is gonna be talking about
how the Bible that's right the Bible led
him to this way of life that's practiced
by over 1.5 billion people from all
across the globe that's right the Bible
led him to Islam and we're gonna find
out how is this possible so for our
Christian neighbors friends Jewish
brethren all the people who are out
there who read this book the Bible how
did someone read the Bible and become a
Muslim it's possible and we're gonna
learn about this person story when we
come back sit tight don't go nowhere
Salaam alaikum peace be with you
a little sample Arvada cotton abdul
malik leblanc leblanc that's right oven
Melvin
how are you I'm did left just assume
that Arabic I did what was that a time
did Allah yah praise be to Allah all
praise be to Allah
now is this something that you defined
in the Bible all praise be to Allah not
exactly there is a there is parts of the
Bible that gives praise to Allah that is
correct
okay so when we say Allah are we talking
about someone God where we tell my when
we say Allah can we said this word twice
enough when we talk about Allah we
simply talking about the one the one God
with no partners no male no female snow
partners we're talking about the one who
holds can't hold the heaven in the earth
in his hand who is has not been seen by
men the one who is the merciful the most
gracious the one who will call us all to
the day of judgement now I opened up the
show and this probably got a lot of
people's attention so they were gonna
tune out possibly some people just tuned
in so for the people that are still with
us they want to know how did the Bible
leads you to Islam how is that possible
so give us a little bit introduction to
this you know and there we can really
dwell into the topic it's been a demand
hang it I grew up as a Catholic I was a
an altar boy in in the Catholic Church
going to church six o'clock in the
morning sometime the only one going to
church and in front of me was mostly
elderly at six o'clock in the morning so
I went through pretty close to the
church all my life I was in the military
in Great Falls Montana
who
is that is that one of the who are you
an army no I was in the Air Force if you
heard this this shout hooah
maybe not an Air Force okay so I was in
the Air Force pretty close again pretty
close to the church learning the Bible
and teaching the Bible to two kids there
I had an opportunity to become a
minister for an AME Church in Great
Falls Montana I decided not to after
many days of contemplation and scary
moments I decided not to while I was in
the military I studied many of the
different religions Hinduism Rastafarian
I Ching Confucius Baptist Catholic
Protestant Episcopal Ian and so forth
but one thing I never found in reading
the Bible where Jesus said I am God and
I think that's a definite we need to
hear that because just as I was at ask
you what's your name and you tell me
your name is that say your name is a
Dean I said you know I continued to call
you Dean and that's not your name you'll
get very angry with me yes so that's a
very important thing so what would be
even more important what's the Jesus to
tell us who he was so if he was God he
would have said I am God but he never
made that statement nor can you go
through the Bible and find out where he
said he he had any attributes of God
that is the merciful they all know her
the forgiver everything that Jesus
talked about he said I do because of the
will of my father he did nothing up on
his own he never said I am God not that
he called himself God nor did he ask of
people to worship Him you will find
nowhere in their way he said asked of
anyone to worship Him one of the
Apostles came to him and said and asked
of him how should we pray and he simply
said our Father as Muslims know you know
when we translate it into our Father our
Father in from an Arabic point of view
is the rub the sustainer and Cherisher
of all the worlds and that was the
prayer he told that that individual to
pray to the one in heaven and also in
that prayer it
talks about asking him for the
forgiveness of your sins giving him your
daily bread leaving you on the right
path
so nowhere will you find in the Bible
where Jesus is telling anyone to worship
Him instead of the one that have sent
him so as you go through it and you you
begin to try and understand it better
you will see that Jesus talked about one
of the greatest Commandments the first
commandment and on two occasions
individuals came to him one will was a
lawyer and another man say what shall I
do to have eternal life what shall I do
to have eternal life the same formula
that exists for all of us from Adam all
the way to now the same for me he said
if you want to have eternal life keep
the commandments
and one of the most important
Commandments is the first four
Commandments thou shalt not have no
other god but one God that is the core
of what we do as Muslims
thou shall not have no other god but one
God so a lot of times you hear Muslims
say la ilaha in the law that means there
is no god but one God so many of these
examples that I that I drew upon are
they're very although they are very
simple they they constitute all that
exists for us that there is only one
creator so for example if you read the
first four Commandments it talks about
iniquity being brought on the third and
fourth generation of them that hate God
when you talk about hate it means
worshiping other than him and we can see
that in our life today we can see how
our generations overtime is getting
worse and worse and worse because we are
worshiping other than our Creator is
this now equivalent when you say
worshiping other than the Creator for
people who out of their their love for
Jesus they end up elevating him to God
so they're making a God next to God is
this equivalent to that what you're
talking about that is egregious or his
mother Jesus peace be upon him told that
they will worship Him uselessly the
teachings of man know where that Jesus
tell anyone to worship Him instead of
the one that have sent him so how do we
in opening the Bible and you have a book
called the Bible led me to Islam that's
how did the Bible II judicial on I think
from from the mini the simple
you know as I began to study about Islam
I wanted a book that compiled everything
into one because you can read some
things from Ahmed Deedat you can read
from from other authors but when I
started compiling all of this and it
slowly moved me the first and first
thing was that clearly Jesus never said
I am God that's clear we got that later
that was right off the bat so that
continued and he never said I am God
so those things moved me away from
saying that Jesus is God because I do
believe those to be very important in
terms of Jesus saying who he is to us
also he never said he is the son of God
as a Christian practicing Christianity
knowing Christianity coming from a
background of Christianity did you
before believe these things that he was
God one in a Trinity son of God
absolutely I think you know that was the
the religion that my mom and dad gave to
me and hamdullah it was it was it was a
platform but you know just like you and
and others out there who may decide well
what university I want to go to what
kind of way to I want to live in life
what kind of wife do I want to have you
know we make all these choices but a lot
of times we we don't make the choices
for religion we simply carry our parents
religious with us I think that we have
to take that backpack off I call it the
backpack of religion and put it in front
of us and go ahead and read the Torah go
ahead and read the Bible go ahead and
read the Quran and make that choice of
your own without being without things
being passed down from you you know
there's new knowledge now back in the
the 50s there was no there was no cure
for cancer but now there was a cure for
cancer so we want to be able to do we
want to be able to share this with
everybody we didn't have that knowledge
back then so let me share this with you
right now
we're gonna take a break and this is
really exciting you have an we're
learning a lot we're gonna sit back and
be back for more here on the Dean show
sit tight
and with wood bees will find that good
breeze would clear out remind in your
heart
of hatred and preconceived notions
racism and nationalism because you
cannot have anything inside of you
that's like that against people and
still be successful
back here on the Dean show with Abdul
Malik Abdul Malik thank you for being
with us thank you and tell us now you're
practicing Christianity you're going
through you know the the you know the
normal worship practices going to church
on Sunday you know you were teaching the
Bible also yes I was I was a Bible ster
I was teaching a Bible studies to two
kids okay so you knew the Bible quite
well
I knew it quite well at what point in
your life did you start to question the
beliefs that were passed down and talk
to you I don't know if there's any
particular point or our time it was it
was a cult
it was a many of the brothers who were
in the Air Force with me we sit down
quite often and talk about the Bible
just have a healthy dialogue let's have
a healthy dialogue and most of us did
not believe at that time that Jesus was
God it was a matter of we were all in
what we call a kind of a neutral ground
yeah we were simply trying to - we
didn't believe that he was God because
some of the things that and biblically
it depended upon the faith of an
individual in order for Jesus to heal
them well from Allah can do whatever he
wants to do it regardless of one faith
or not it doesn't need that component in
order for him to do what he wants to do
so many of the things that Jesus spoke
about himself we spoke about Allah that
all those things was a culmination of
things just things that kind of continue
to move you toward you know it what for
example there's one in the Bible that
says pray without ceasing yes it's in
things first Thessalonians it's play
without ceasing now youyou could it's
possible you can do that just simply
with your tongue but when I met this
Muslim brother in 1985 when he showed me
things on how to go to bed at night and
be in a state of worship when he told me
he taught me how to how to perform we'll
do the same as this is all a part of
being in the state of worship how
you know when I enter a room or when I
exit a room or when I'm in the presence
of non-muslims a presence of one of a
women or when I putting on my clothes he
was able to show me how I can be in the
state of Nevada state of worship 24
hours a day without having to keep the
remembrance on my tongue yeah so when I
met this brother his name is fuzzy
Senate he's from Bahrain when I met him
him and I were in the Air Force together
and he had a he had a we were we were we
were in the room and his bed was here
mine was here in one morning
if you don't mind me to go into this one
morning I heard him making some noise
over there at the sink a little loose so
I kind of looked up and I saw him and
then he took his foot and put it inside
of the sink and I said to myself well if
that's the way he washed that the way he
wash so that day when I came back for my
lunch I saw him on the ground
prostrating in the room so I came and
got my stuff in and I left and then the
next day he stayed away that night the
next day I came in for lunch also and I
saw him do the same thing so that
evening I asked him I said I said what
are you doing there he said he said I'm
praying I asked him who you're praying
to he said I'm praying to God I said
what God he said to one God and then I
asked him I said well what religion are
you he said I am Muslim and then I asked
I said you know Louis Farrakhan you
thought it was the nation I thought it
was the nation yeah I said you know
Louis Farrakhan he said no I said you
know Malcolm X he said no and I said
well what kind of Muslim are you he said
I'm the old Muslim so this gentleman was
able to teach me the how to's everything
that the Bible told us the what Islam
tells you the how to's like for example
honor your father and your mother yes it
clearly says honor your father and your
mother in the fifth commandment but
Islam tells you how to do that let alone
the law there is no God
one God Islam tells you how to do that
pray without ceasing Islam tells you how
to do that treating your neighbors
correctly Islam tells you how to do that
so when I met this brother I I was able
to bring all these things together
through the religion of Islam because it
gave me it gave me the how to's Islam
gave me the how to the Bible gave me the
fundamentals Islam gave me the how to's
so bringing those two together I believe
the Bible led me to Islam so do you see
now that you have consciously children
to submit to the one God that's what a
Muslim is I'm doing that practicing
Islam my mission to the one guy and
that's how you get peace do you see that
remnants of it in the Bible you do
people if they're looking at there those
who are Christian those who follow the
first five books and then the Old
Testament and New Testament is this an
extension now is this the the final
completion of all the revelations and
how can people if they're also confused
about the Trinity if they're also
confused of you know of their religion
that things just don't make sense and
they want to make sense of at all and if
they're still not ready to you know let
go of what they have can they dig a
little deeper and then will it lead them
to where it led you why can't you know
hamdullah we all know that Hidayah did
this this nature to become Muslim or to
seek Islam comes from Allah yes they
just have to be willing they just have
to be willing to be open and elect a lot
lead them they're listening to us today
they can simply said I said this when I
met Fozzy I knew there were there was
five things about him that intrigued me
one he was 26 year old 26 years old and
he was a virgin too he was an athlete a
superior athlete and I know coming up in
America an athlete then 26 years old
virgin they don't go together so you
know if you have if you an athlete you
definitely gonna do to our the kiss or
touch one but he wasn't back that if he
if you had to fight he could yeah so
there was nothing you know wrong with
him he had Brotherhood and he
was religious one thing fuzzy taught me
because he showed me the spirit of the
law we were watching TV one evening and
he happened to see a cleavage of a woman
and he did this he turned his head like
that when I saw that that told me
that's his LOM because the Bible teaches
you the spirit of it so every time he
saw he saw a woman not dressed properly
he turned his head like that that taught
me something that was Islam in action
that was Islam in action so I figured
that Fozzie should have been on The
Oprah Winfrey Show because there was
would be no one like him who would show
those kinds of attributes here in
America amazingamazing let-let's before
we move a little bit forward tell us
because you made a bold statement you
said Jesus never claimed to be God never
call people to worship and himself a few
passages that people and I'm sure you've
heard these before he's an I in the
father one yeah
surely I surely we I in the father I
want not not in terms of not in terms of
you know like like the egg having three
parts or like the tree having three
parts not in relation to that one in
what there was he was supposed to do he
simply came to do the will of the Father
so what he was supposed to do is the
oneness of that not so much one in terms
of being together three and one and so
forth no in what he was told to come and
do that was the oneness of it now
someone says you know what I don't
believe that Jesus is God but he said
because it's in the Bible that no one
comes to the Father except through me so
I just pray through Jesus because he's
the son of God
ya know that I that heard that yes that
is based on belief yeah you have to know
as Muslims we believe in Jesus
so that's accepting him coming here on
earth there are others who do not
believe that Jesus came here on earth
for example I mentioned earlier about
how do we pray Jesus told an individual
how to pray he said our Father
orab who is in heaven give us this day
our daily bread and forgive us our sins
so all that we can ask for is is written
inside that that prayer they're very
similar prayer to surah al fatiha
which we have is bismillah r-rahman
r-rahim in the name of Allah most
gracious most merciful
so you have to be willing you know
there's a lot of things out there that
can prevent one I had one one brother
over in Saudi Arabia a 35 year old man
after hearing about Islam called his
father and asked his father could he
become Muslim because there are a lot of
things that prepend prevent us from
becoming Muslim exterior even more now
there are a lot of things out there that
would prevent someone form from becoming
Muslim just because of the propaganda
but if you read about Islam
let me get back to this brother the
father told him son if that's what you
want to do go ahead and then do it so
there's a lot of external things we have
to kind of rid ourselves of with and and
and for example when I did the Shahada
my Shahada I was at a stoplight in
Denver Colorado and I said oh Allah
I don't know Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him but it falls he knows him
didn't teach him to me so I give the
same thing to our audience today yes
they may have heard new things today go
ahead on and say Allah if what these
brothers are saying is the truth and
guided me to the right path and Allah
will take care of that now someone's a
little bit timid of using the word Allah
we know that law is not a moon god he's
not a man or a woman he's the creator of
all that is he's the one God and didn't
Jesus in Aramaic did he say aloha aloha
aloha
that is correct so if they don't want to
use this word they're a little timid how
else could they call upon the Creator oh
god oh god oh god but if they got a
mental picture of him like old man you
know that with a big beard and that
doesn't work no because no one has seen
his shape not heard his voice that's
clearly written in the Bible no one has
seen his shape not heard his voice so I
think it's sincerity it's all about your
eternity inside of your heart if you
simply say in reference you know you
make the prayer because God knows Allah
knows the prayer that you're going to
pray okay so make that prayer and ask
him if what we're saying today is the
right thing bring me closer to it and
with that we're going to take another
break and we'll be right back with more
here on the Deen show
back here on the Dean show with my guest
Melvin Melvin that's right and we're
almost out of time I want to ask you a
few more questions you have a book it's
called the Bible led me to Islam that's
correct
so we talked about that also you have a
explanation of Islam and it's you know
in the pamphlet called Islam so simple
I'm so Sam so can you go ahead and for
those people who also have watched some
of our shows and you know they're really
interested in what we have to say that
they like what Islam is about they like
this this way of life that cause people
to just worship God to just worship the
creator and to do good deeds righteous
deeds it calls people to accountability
their judgment paradise the wonderful
rewards its sanity in the most wonderful
places that you can be the terrifies
Hellfire accountability so how do you
explain Islam to those people without
all the confusion making it very simple
I tell them as you mentioned Aramaic
Allah Jesus if he will say the God he
would say ilaha if he would say the DAAD
one Allah means the God to Islam is
simply the religion of submission three
a Muslim is simply one who submit those
are three things that we basically say
is LOM is not nothing new the
prostration of the prayer the
prostration as we prostrate on the
ground we we know in the Bible Jesus
fell to his face many times you look
through the New Testament you will see
they that they say they fell between
their knees so the prostration isn't
nothing new we know that Jesus when he
met his companions he would say peace be
with you
as brothers as Muslim brothers say
assalamualaikum we know that that's not
new also we the the a pollution the
cleanliness that we do we know that
Moses did that the call to prayer that
we give calling people to prayer we know
that Moses used to do it with a horn
that there is Islam is not nothing new
Jesus peace be upon him did not eat pork
so if my Christian brothers are out
there who are eating pork you know to be
more christ-like you definitely got to
get rid of it so many things like that
simple things that should just just make
chatter and falsehood in our mind to
allow us to say okay for example he said
we need to love the Lord thy God with
all thy strength with all thy soul with
all thy might with all that mind that's
Islam that's lair in now in the law
having no other partners having no one
not money not desires not lust not home
not work no other no other creator but
Allah a couple more points tell us now a
person has put their whole hope and
ambition and their their dream now is to
go to paradise and they've been told
since childhood that you know what Jesus
he died for your sins so now they're
stuck here they don't want to let this
go because they feel like they're gonna
sacrifice paradise for that what do you
got to talk to tell them if you want to
have eternal life keep the commandments
one of the very first Commandments you
need to have is thou shalt not have no
other God but one God Jesus said that on
more than one occasion if you want to
have eternal life keep the commandments
the foremost one that the foremost one
is the first for thou shalt not have no
other God but one God that is the way
you get that is the same formula that
exists from beginning to end that's the
formula from Adam all the way to
nowadays us that's the formula if you
want to have eternal life keep the
commandments
the greatest commandment is there a lie
how in the law there is no god but one
God the people also now they hear a lot
of negative there's a lot of false
representation by the media people feel
that look you know Islam is about you
know blowing things up and people
getting blown up and terrorism and
terrorizing what do I say about this
that's not Islam I wouldn't bring my
kids up in it if that was Islam I
wouldn't raise my kids as Muslim and I
was raised and in the southern part of
the Louisiana where everybody raised me
if I did something wrong down the street
my neighbors were with me and then when
I get home my father would with me so I
would not want my kids to be raised in
something other than what is correct are
you an Arab now so you're still American
what you know when you become a Muslim
do you become a indo-pak no I heard you
become a neighborhood that would go now
I'm an african-american and I'm a Muslim
that's it that's the jet you gotta get
dipped in a pool you got to do some snow
crazy rituals you don't have to do that
it's just the testimony of the tongue
because Allah knows is sincerity I work
with inmates and I tell inmates you can
fool me but you can't fool God so if you
say I bear witness that there is no God
worthy of worship except Allah then you
have to be sincere about that and that
you can't fool a lot and it's best for
you not to play around with God because
he can you don't want his wrath to be
upon you last closing comments and
suggestions where people could get in
contact with you to read some of your
books and also for that person that's
right there they again you know didn't
like what we had to say they're confused
with all the other beliefs I've been
brought up into and they just you know
the family friends you know the social
environment they're a little bit you
know nervous now they want to take that
step that leap of faith but they just
need a little bit encouragement talk to
us right there I say I say brothers you
know you you know what's in your heart
brothers and sisters you know what's in
your heart and you know as as well as I
know you cannot tell if you've never
been to New York and someone asked you
how is New York you cannot tell them New
York is bad simply because you heard it
on television it's best for you to go
ahead and read about it the best thing I
can ask you to do is go to the nearest
Masjid that's what the brother Fozzy did
to me he took me to the Masjid in Denver
Colorado and I asked the questions I
needed to ask that's the thing you want
to do the analogy I gave you can't deny
something or condemn something you don't
have understanding of okay best to think
I give you an example my father thought
I was an Iranian terrorist because I
became Muslim in 1985 and the only thing
was going on at the time was Terry
Anderson being taken hostage but over
the years my father noticed that him and
I became closer the last words that my
father said before he died was give me
water Melvin so only Allah knows that
but what I say to you is just you know
read as you did to pursue your degree
what wife where you want to live okay
what kind of job you want what kind of
salary you want to make or have go down
and take the books put the books in
front of you and read them
the Quran don't be afraid of it when you
read the Quran don't read it like you
read the Bible read it so Allah can lift
things up for you because if you read it
like you read the Bible you will not
understand it because it doesn't have a
chronological order to it it's a
revelation so that's what I would say to
the brothers - - don't say something
that you have no knowledge of go ahead
and in secret and then ask Allah ask God
to lead you to the right path if what we
are talking about today is the truth
thank you very much nothing like a God
Almighty the creator of law thank you
very much I reward you thank you thank
you God and thank you for sitting tight
through another episode of the Deen show
great advice from somebody who was there
and he's here now and he read the Bible
and the Bible led him to this beautiful
way of life this way of life that brings
peace and contentment to one's life
satisfaction happiness and eternity in
paradise living for God living your life
to be the best human being that you can
be read this book the verbatim Word of
God you get it for free one eight
hundred six six - Islam give us a call
pick up your copy and come back here to
the Deen show every week and until next
time peace be unto you